Apple Computer was established in 1976 by Ronald Wayne, Steve Wozniak, and Steve Jobs.
After only two weeks, Wayne left the company and sold his 10% stock for $800.
If he'd kept those 10% to this day, it would be worth over 60 billion.
A few months after Wayne's departure, Apple released the Apple I.
Steve Wozniak developed and designed both the hardware and operating system.
In fact, the Apple I was the first time in history...
...that a character displayed on a TV screen was generated by a home computer.
Only a year later, Wozniak developed the Apple II,...
...the first PC with color.
In 1984, Apple launched the first Macintosh.
In 1985, something interesting happened.
A power struggle developed between Jobs and then CEO John Sculley.
As a result of this, Apple's board of directors removed Jobs from his management duties,...
...which in turn led to his resignation from the company the same year.